hello everyone this is Peter Cooper from
the NCBI today's webinar is about the
new refseq functional elements project
and Katherine Farrell
one of the refseq people is going to be
talking about that and all the questions
even if we don't know the answer is now
we will find the mouth and we'll put
them in a QA document okay so I'm going
to turn this over to Katherine hello
everyone this is Katherine fired from
the refseq project and here i'm showing
you the refseq homepage and today i'm
going to be talking to you specifically
about the refseq functional elements
part of the project which is highlighted
here before I do that I just want to
remind you of what the refseq scope has
been so far up until love and part NCBI
eukaryotic genome annotation content has
been and so so far we have been
annotated genes which can either be
protein coding or non-coding and the
refseq accessions and have prefixes that
other enemies are NPS for proteins or
XM's XPS for mortal accessions that are
protein coding and/or direct source for
non-coding transcripts we've also been
annotated in pseudo genes which can be
transcribed or non transcribed the
non-transcribed one sketch ng accessions
and we've also been annotating genomic
regions or segments which ng accessions
and these have been typically regions
containing multiple genes or segments
such as immunoglobulin gene segments or
we also have refseq gene representations
for clinically relevant gene regions and
her use as a foundation for variant
reporting so all of these we consider to
be conventional gene type annotations
however there are some points that we
need to bear in mind and though that is
that only about 1.1 percent of the human
genome is actually protein coding less
than 2 percent of the genome has
conventional gene type annotation when
you include non-coding genes and
pseudogenes as well as a protein
hauling genes and it's also known from
recent research particularly G was
studies that a lot of disease associated
variation is occurring in the non-coding
genome so that leads us to the question
of what other functional content is
present in the Eukarya genome and and
it's knowing that there are gene
regulatory elements such as enhancers
silencers promoters transcription factor
binding sites locus control regions and
such as this example shown here we there
are also structural elements including
boundary elements matrix attachment
regions and other structural regions
associated with chromatin confirmation
and there are also elements involved in
other regulatory processes or such as
DNA recombination or repair DNA
replication or chromosome maintenance or
stability and it's known that variation
and all of those regions can can result
in disease and also higher order
chromatin structure and epigenomic
modifications are important for many of
these functional processes so with that
in mind we decided to do to annotate
refseq functional elements and the
project overview has this workflow where
we would take known elements that have
been well defined and experimentally
validated in the literature we would
take gel from PubMed to read the records
as well as data from certain databases
such as the list enhancer cancer
database that has experimentally
validated enhancers and we would also
use data from collaborators to enhance
that experimental a validated data hit
when necessary and the curated records
would be two of two types one would be a
record in the gene database which would
contain a lot of metadata and I will
demonstrate that later in this talk
we would also produce a refseq record an
NCBI is nucleotide database and those
records are then used to to release an
FTP downloads on ncbi's websites and
they're used in ncbi genome annotation
and available on genome browsers so what
is the scope of the refseq functional
element project first I want to give the
definition of what we consider to be a
non-genic functional element and that is
any genomic element that has functional
significance based on experimental
support and it's not otherwise
considered to be a conventional gene and
that types that we are representing
include gene regulatory elements such as
enhancers silencers promoters also
structural elements such as boundary
elements matrix attachment regions and
also other elements of functional
important for example well-defined or
clinically significant recombination
hotspots our DNA replication origins our
annotations scope for those elements is
for elements that have to be
experimentally valid in the literature
and we are only representing human and
less elements right now with some
prioritization for elements that are
implicated in human disease I also want
to point out what refseq functional
elements are not going to represent and
that is there we are not representing
predictors or imputed elements from
large-scale epigenomic studies such as
those that are covered in other
resources like they encode or NIH
roadmap epigenomics projects or the
insolvent regulatory build in addition
the elements we are representing they're
not as restrictive as those and those
other resources with respect to element
types because we can include element
types us and cannot be readily predicted
by epigenome mapping studies alone an
example would be DNA recombination
regions or gene regulatory
her described that her defined by a
particular experimental type such as
locus control regions um and it's also
important to remember that since this is
just a new dataset and we just had an
initial release that this dataset is not
complete yet so you may not find your
favorite gene regulatory element and it
is at this point in time so now I want
to describe the genomic refseqs that we
are making for these functional elements
and these refseqs will have ng accession
prefixes so they will span the genomic
range of one or more experimentally
validated functional element and where
we are grouping closely situated and
highly related elements together for
example a cluster of enhancers that
regulate the same gene would be included
on the same ng accession all of her
accessions would be associated with
nci's bioproject accession as shown here
and you will identify those records on
the flat file at the top there will be a
DB link to that bio project accession
and we also will include a parental
region feature on all of those records
which will be marked up as a biological
region such as this example on a flat
file so all of these records will have a
lot of feature annotation where all our
features are in accordance with insdc
specifications and shown here is the
insdc website and their feature table
that defines and lists all the different
definitions that I have um we are also
using controlled vocabularies from the
sequence ontology and when the insdc
feature is not very descriptive such as
if it's a just called a misc feature we
will use sequence ontology terms
such as this example like conserved
region and we also want to include
experimental qualifiers and other
features to indicate the type of
experimental evidence that exists for
the future and we want to include at
least one evidence code from the
evidence and conclusion ontology and
that's called an echo ID as shown in the
highlighted example and we also want to
include at least one citation from
PubMed so users can then click on the
PubMed ID link and see the publication
on those records and we are also using
other and insdc qualifiers and our
feature annotation pan applicable such
as feature class qualifiers and those
applied to both regulatory class
features such as this example shown here
or recombination class features and such
as a mitotic recombination hotspot
examples are shown here we also include
no qualifiers with further details from
the literature as shown here in this
example and we also include dbx ref
qualifiers to crossdress cross-reference
database records and and this example
shows the cross-reference to the gene ID
for this particular refseq and there
will be other qualifiers were for
certain features such as abandoned
moiety for protein bind features or if a
function is no 1 for a particular
feature that we can also indicate
details for those so now I'll describe
the gene records that we are
representing and the gene record is a
central location with integrated data
from various sources and here is an
example of one such record and here I
want to point out the top part where we
have a gene type called biological
region for all of these records we are
also going to display
feature types based on the feature
annotation on the Associated refseq we
also display other information such as
symbols and aliases from the literature
as well as refseq summary that gives a
summary of what the region is and what
type of elements are involved in that
particular region we also show an ortho
log records links to ortho log records
if that's if there is one in the mouse
ortholog and the gene record also
contains other typical areas including
like a citation section with a link to
PubMed with religious publications or
related sequences and gene record also
contains a feature annotation graphical
display and right now that it's the gene
annotation is not shown automatically by
default because we only have the
annotation done in an NCBI interim
annotation so it doesn't I want to draw
your attention to their tracks button on
the top right where you would need to
turn on the configure page and turn on
particular these particular tracks that
are marked and these show up on the
browser like this and in the biological
regions track you will see all of the
feature annotations for the particular
region and those features are color
coded according to insdc classifications
and if you mouse over the title of one
of those features such as this locus
control region feature you can bring up
a pop-up box with for them information
about that feature and that will include
all of the qualifiers that I have
previously described such as they
experiment qualifier with links to
PubMed IDs as well as you can also turn
on links to a sequence if you want to
obtain that sequence from there
and here I'm showing a list of feature
keys and feature classes and other
controlled vocabularies that we have
used so far and and these are a list of
features that have appeared on ncbi's
human interim annotation I want to point
out that many of our features are
regulatory class features and we have a
particular high amount of enhancer
features we also have a lot of miss
Wickham features where most of those are
either meiotic recombination hotspots or
they're non allelochemicals
recombination regions and in addition we
have several protein binding sites that
are experimentally validated in the
literature the current genome annotation
status as I mentioned previously is
based on interim annotations and we have
that data available in GF f3 format on
our FTP site as well as an NCBI
graphical view tracks as I showed in two
slides ago and we have that for both
human and mouse and here is an example
of our FTP site for the human
annotations so you need to go to that
particular path to find the file and I
the highlighted file is the one which is
our most recent interim annotation so
our future plans are to do a full NCBI
genome annotation for both human and us
and we expect a human annotation to be
released and late this year within the
next month or two we will do more we'll
continue to do more curation to produce
more functional element records and we
will provide links of gene targets for
particular elements or links of elements
that interact which with each other in
her gene records we will also provide
links to example regulatory build
accessions that overlap refseq
functional element features and we are
also working with UCSC to provide a UCSC
genome browser track
more information is available on our
website and I want to point out the data
access sections where you can actually
find lots more information on how to
access our data and you can access it
via gene nucleotide blast or bioproject
and NCBI databases as well as we are
NCBI graphical displays and the FTP
sites and finally I want to remind you
to stay tuned to the auntie VI insights
blog and NCBI social media for future
announcements at refseq functional
elements so thank you for listening and
if there were any questions thanks very
much Kathryn this is Peter Cooper again
so whilst leave the questions pod open
for a few minutes if anybody has any
questions please type them in there okay
well there don't seem to be any
questions right now but if you have any
questions about the material that we
talked about today you can certainly
write to our help desk the addresses
info at NCBI NLM . nih.gov if you have
any questions about the webinar series
write to our webinars address which is
webinars at NCBI
NLM th gov thanks very much for coming
and we're going to go ahead and the
webinar now
you